the economic effects of the corona virus
pandemic are also being felt in many
sectors of the global economy aviation
and oil in particular and they're
hitting the biggest players after
already announcing it would cut aircraft
production by a third and that the
company was quote bleeding cash at an
unprecedented speed the plane making
giant airbus has posted a first quarter
loss of half a billion dollars the CEO
is warning this is the gravest crisis
the industry has ever known its rival
Boeing already announced plans to cut as
many as 7,000 jobs the company's chief
executive predicts global revenues could
drop by over 300 billion dollars this
year in the industry and it would take
years to recover and on top of all that
the UK's national carrier British
Airways is set to cut up to 12,000 jobs
which is around a third of its workforce
the airline suspended 96% of its flights
for April and May we've got Tom
Ballantine with us now on skype he is
the associate editor and chief
correspondent of orient aviation from
Sydney thank you Tom good to see you
I mean no mess of surprised that airbus
has lost this much money but I guess
it's the knock-on effect isn't it the
next quarter and the next quarter out
there in fact as the Boeing boss was
saying for years afterwards yes Kemal I
mean the situation is as the Airbus boss
said very grave and things are going to
get worse in the second quarter the fact
is very aircraft there 90% of the
world's fleet is sitting on the ground
and the last thing you're going to want
at the moment is to take delivery of
more seats that they'll have to park I
know that airlines around the world are
currently right now in discussion with
both Airbus and Boeing looking at Nadi
not only cancellations but certainly
many deferrals of the deliveries because
they simply don't want these aircraft
right now I hate to oversimplify here
but if the plane makers can't make
planes and the carrier's can't fly
planes there's no industry and I bet
could be a short-term thing because the
the the lockdowns could be lifted we
could see a change but but even so the
the industry's changed it will have to
change yes absolutely I mean
we all know now that this recovery when
it comes is not going to be a sharp
v-shaped recovery it's going to be a
long u-shaped recovery and it's going to
be a long time before the air transport
network is good going to be back where
it was before the crisis we're talking
about a year up to two years so that's I
love a lot of time for airlines to hold
out for the plane makers to hold out and
they certainly need all the help they
can get from governments from their
investors and these governments and
investors are also facing economic
problems are facing recession shortages
of cash all around so it's going to be a
long time before the the industry has
any chance of returning to what isn't
going to be normal but some sort of
normal I think it's not inconceivable
that some airlines will go to the wall
on this they may go and or as in British
Airways case having to majorly
reconstruct the size of the company but
if the plane makers themselves get into
that situation I mean what happens are
these companies considered in there like
the banks the too big to fail because
there's only really two big players
pretty much that's the case I mean the
fact is there are only two big big
players and if you look at Airbus I mean
they're essentially owned by four
governments the UK Spain France and
Germany they do have quite a lot of cash
reserves despite what is happening at
the moment Boeing is also a big company
and in the case of Boeing it gets
something like 34 percent of its
revenues not from commercial jets but
from the defense and aerospace divisions
of its company Airbus on the other hand
gets only about 20 percent of its
revenues from defense so they are more
reliant on the jet commercial jet market
and Boeing are there's no question that
they they will not collapse they will
see this through but they're not going
to come out the other end the same
Tom I could sit into a cave iation with
you all day but I do have to get to some
other news thank you so much for your
time do appreciate it